I am not one to film people in public,
but crossing the street right now
in front of me is this woman who looks like a literal Barbie doll.
She is probably in her 50s,
but she looks immaculate. Low rise,
flared jeans, blonde hair,
bouncy curls. Fucking gorgeous. Stunning.
The man she's with looks like a backwards weeble wobble,
um, who's also one foot out of the grave.
And I just think it's so interesting
that we are so accustomed to seeing that,
we're so accustomed to seeing women who look fucking perfect
with men
who look like they crawled out of some sort of primordial ooze
that we don't even blink an eye.
Right? But if we were to see the roles reversed,
if we were to see a handsome,
stunning, perfect 10 of a man with a woman who is like
maybe a half step lower than him on the general beauty standard
attractiveness scale, they would eat her alive.
People would have so much to say about it,
because we are not used to seeing that,
and we don't like seeing it,
and it's absolute nonsense.